thank you
foreign
everyone and welcome to the house
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs we have three bills
that we're going to be hearing that have
come over from the Senate but before we
get into those I'd like you to please
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
thank you everyone
first build uh to be heard this morning
is um Senate Bill 127 and I'll recognize
morning Senator good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee pleasure to be
back here
I sponsored this bill as I've done for I
think the last three or four sessions
for the Department of Health and Human
Services
to make certain
technical changes and this is largely a
technical change bill
um
past the Senate unanimously as I recall
and I bring it to you I can walk through
very briefly what these changes are
there are some 10 or 12 of them but I
think
your time might be better spent hearing
from the Department who asked me to file
the bills so with that I'll take any
questions or I can you know touch base
on what each of the sections does but I
think John Williams will do a much
better job than me if that's all right
with you sir sure attorney Williams has
made that offer and he's indicated there
are a number of Department individual
people from the Department to uh to do
so while Senator Bradley is before us
does anyone have a question for him or
okay I'm sitting on so and I would just
thank you again for the very gracious
hearing last week on Senate Bill 263 I
appreciate that very much and thank you
okay attorney Williams would you like to
come forward and
I guess you have a uh you have quite a
fighter cast with you today
chairman McDonald and members of the
House Health Human Services elderly
Affairs committee for the record my name
is John Williams I am the director of
legislative affairs for the New
Hampshire Department of Ed Department of
Education not really but Department of
Health and services and I wanted to
thank the committee and also our Prime
sponsor Senator Bradley for bringing
this important legislation uh forward
and we look forward uh to presenting
this to you uh you may recall last
session we did bring Senate Bill 430
that Bill had 73 sections the bill
before you I had to report to you that
has 16 sections so we did get the memo
on making sure that we were more tight
and that we made sure that the
appropriate subject matter went to the
respective committee so containing this
bill are issues subject matters that
would be relevant to this group and we
we thank you for your time and
appreciation so as I walk you through
the legislation we're going to start
with sections one and two of the bill
and that begins on page one lines one
three Row 18 and you may recall for
those of you who served on the committee
last session that we brought before you
a request to establishing a dedicated
fund within our opioid treatment
prevention program and at the time you
did establish the fund and as we learned
after the bill had been signed into law
it could have been fixed through an
enrolled build process but there was an
incorrect cross-reference to the
legislation as to where the fees would
be collected from so fees are collected
in support of the in support of the
program through a provision under the
controlled Drug Act and it allows for
the Department to use those fees that
are collected to support the program
activities around the opioid treatment
prevention program so the underlying
policy for that change was adopted by
the legislature and passed this
committee but we're here today to
correcting the improper cross reference
and getting you to the correct
cross-reference as it relates to that
particular section and I would just draw
your attention on sections one and two
first starting on line eight you'll see
that we're making the appropriate
cross-reference to the fund that you
created under RSA 172 eight
see within the controlled Drug Act
section where the fees are established
and then made the appropriate
cross-reference within that particular
RSA in the fund so that the funding
as I go through this if it's helpful I
can break for questions and move on to
the next section so I sing no questions
any questions so far
okay all right well that will take us up
to sections uh three and four and I'd
like to invite up at this time attorney
Brian Clark Brian Clark and he is
general counsel within our legal and
Regulatory services but particularly
he's here on the sections three and four
as it relates to his role as general
counsel for the Bureau of elderly and
Adult Services and so sections three and
four the bill address a Workforce
capacity issue you may recall that you
folks passed legislation recently to
expand the scope of who could provide uh
care personal care services for
individuals who have been deemed both
financially and clinically eligible for
purposes of receiving long-term care in
a community-based setting particularly
up in the rural areas where there is not
a sufficient Workforce to meet the
demand for those individuals who have
been found eligible that this Builds on
what we've done in past sessions where
we've opened it up to allowing family
members who are you know qualified to
doing these kind of services to provide
for those individuals who are eligible
so that's already an existing law so
this expands on that to include also
Guardians and those have been quarter
pointed with powers of attorneys and
you'll see those changes represented in
sections uh three and four of the
legislation which takes you from page
one line 19 through page two line uh 20
hello chairman any questions for
attorney Clark or myself any questions
so far
no so far so good all right thank you
that takes us now to page two line 21 uh
through uh page three line four uh these
sections excuse me representative Weber
I'm sorry I'm a little similar on the
would you remind
counter-intuitive as I look at the
language I know that's because I don't
have the rest of the statute in front of
me but if you could just explain it to
me quickly uh
the first
part uh on lines 19 through uh
when she through 30 and and following uh
says personal care service provider and
who they are and who they're not and and
the legally responsible relative is
accepted out there
but I'm remembering that we said we put
in at one point the fact that we
recognized that responsible relatives
are providing an enormous amount of care
and perhaps they ought to be reimbursed
by it uh so
it takes them out all the way up to line
five and then uh
so it just we're just saying that's not
a personal care
services provider but we're allowing
them to earn anyway under section four
is that how it works
yes that's correct so okay by default
they would not be included but we have
ways to authorize them and when they're
needed yes and you wanted specifically
to keep those separate is that correct
right so we're also adding the process
to authorize Guardians and Powers of
Attorney okay thank you appreciate it
okay go ahead thank you and Joe McDonald
thank you that now brings us to the next
two related sections which are sections
five and six of the bill on found on
page two uh line 21 through Page Three
line 24 and uh this also relates to law
um long-term care and as you know
individuals who are in settings either
assist living or nursing facilities they
are allowed a small amount of money per
month for personal care items such as
things for toothbrushes and things like
that for their care so what this section
does is to ensure that that money is not
to be used for other things such as
providing for room and board we have
discuss this with the provider community
and they have been universally
supportive of this particular provision
and I didn't know if you've had any
questions I know that attorney Clark
might want to add on to section six of
the bill what that piece of the bill
does uh also in as we work through the
process in advance of the hearing in the
Senate we also work with New Hampshire
legal assistants and I thoughtfully work
through some of the issues relative to
foreign
six of the bill
um adds a requirement to a residential
care facility residency agreements that
um they cannot require third parties to
pay for the residential care facility
service
other than for add-ons like a private
I thought that it was already a
requirement that a certain amount of
money be put into a discretionary fund
for a nursing home patient that wasn't
that there was the piece that dick
supposed to be protected within the
processary but um apparently that's not
the case that the shores up the issues
okay you understand the question to go
ahead uh could you restate the question
sure right now my mother was in a
nursing home and they had told me years
ago when she was there that they were
required to put a certain amount of
money aside for personal needs like
sometimes they take them out to riding
around Christmas lights or whatever or
whatever it was like they'd stop for an
ice cream or something and just
miscellaneous personal things and I
thought that was already a requirement
but but it isn't actually so so there is
a provision and your memory is spot on
there's a provision in state law that
requires the facility that's holding the
individual like for even at New
Hampshire hospital we have similar trust
funds that are set up for personal care
allowances so there is that in place
however invading that trust for these
purposes need to be clarified in state
law because apparently there have been
in some instances where those funds have
been sought for purposes of
um somewhat reimbursement for these room
and board items so okay thank you
go ahead continue please and that now
takes us up to section seven I'd like to
invite up at this time attorney Robert F
Berry Jr to join me he is the general
counsel for our Department's division
for Medicaid services he works with
Henry Lipman so it means he's the Brain
Trust in a very bright man uh very
bright attorney uh in the next section
of the bill that we're here before you
is section seven found on page three
lines 15 through 13. this is one that um
we've been actually identifying for for
a few years now for
um trying to to address and it's it's
meant to be business friendly so we have
this thing called the nursing facility
quality assessment uh and those those
assessments are used as part of our our
rates that we we provide around certain
Lawn Care
matters so what this bill does is it
says to the provider to the nursing
facility who's having to report to the
Department of Health Unit services and
also to revenue Administration who
receives these fees that you don't have
to report to us at hhf we're trying to
take one unnecessary step away for them
because we get that information directly
from the Department of Revenue
Administration as part of the process so
with that um it's meant to be business
friendly and it's it's an item that
we've been looking to take care of for a
few years now and I'd like to turn it
over to attorney Barry if he has any
other thoughts uh nothing more to add
other than it just really is meant to
eliminate duplicate duplicative
processes and ensure some efficiency
among paperwork that's moving between
various agencies and the nursing
facility industry
okay thank you representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman I I did not catch
where that is in the bill oh
that's okay thank you very much section
seven is found on page three lines 5
thank you
another questions uh representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking the question out of curiosity
why would apple cider not be considered
a fruit juice to begin with and that
would be the next section that we'll be
addressing
okay thank you okay representative Nagel
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
like I'm just curious why that you would
have had to report to two different
entities in the beginning why that was
me so so the way that uh the imequip
payment used to be calculated which is
Medicaid quality incentive and I forget
the P stands for payment or program so
forgive me for that
um but what would happen was the
department would originally get the uh
the information and use that to
calculate the mqp payment uh CMS is uh
subsequently said that we can't do that
we need it based on actual uh monies
received which we get from dra
subsequent to that so this makes the the
other questions
okay
thank you and chairman McDonald that now
takes us to sections eight and none of
the bill I'd like to invite up uh Miss
Pauline Smith she's an administrator
with the Department's division of Public
Health Services Under food protection
and we are here today now on sections
eight and nine of the bill found on page
three lines 14 through 32 and that gets
us to represent Merchant's question
regarding the change to uh apple cider
and from a food Protection Service we
have the best person to answer the
question here because you'll see that we
deleted other types of fruit juices so
we needed to get more clarity about what
was actually being required to getting a
license under the water bottling and
juices item so I will turn it over to
good morning thank you for allowing me
to speak to this bill the beverage and
bottled water program it primarily
regulates hosts wholesalers of Beverages
and bottled water in the state there are
a few exceptions to that milk products
because they're regulated under the
dairy sanitation program within the
department but there was also a part of
the statute that allowed someone that's
making a fruit juice or bottled water
direct to Consumer to be to not have a
license so we're amending that so if you
are making a fruit juice or bottled
water you would be required to have a
license but with the exception of 100
apple cider so this would allow apple
orchards that are pressing cider
exclusively for distribution direct to
Consumer to not have our license as as
has been the case in the past the other
substantial change is is that there was
also a provision that if someone was
bottling a beverage regardless and this
would be like a lemonade if so if it's a
grocery store bottling lemon Aid they
would require this beverage license plus
they could also hold a regular retail
food license so this would eliminate
that double licensing so if they were
regulated under the retail food program
they could just have the one license and
it will have minimal fiscal impact but
certainly the the industry would it's
it's streamlining regulation over the
the industry not having two regular two
regulatory inspectors oversee the same
operation essentially
and and if I could just uh just restate
at a very high level because
um Miss Smith is very knowledgeable in
her area what what is happening here in
the state there are what we call
self-inspecting towns uh like Concord
and some of the larger towns and um and
then there are ones that fall under the
oversight of the department as it
currently exists if you have a
restaurant for example that you sell
bottled water and you have a license to
under our food protection what this bill
would do is say you don't also have to
have a second license for bottled water
that's what this does it's business
friendly and it's meant to uh there is a
modicum of small loss of some uh fees to
the state of New Hampshire as a result
of it but we think it's a positive
because we're covering for that entity
based upon that one license as opposed
to requiring a second duplicative
license uh
okay thank you representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
for taking a question and sorry for
jumping the gun
um my apologies
in regards to I would be a nitpicky here
but if I read this
the way it's written
if I have a lemonade stand do I have to
have a license
if you if you have a lemonade stand do I
have to have a license because it's a
root gun straight
because I
wouldn't be under this program it would
if it meant the criteria of a retail
food license because you're selling
direct to Consumer
um you wouldn't have these are this
right this program is is
mainly wholesaling of beverages it
wouldn't
um if you if your lemonade stand met the
criteria for a retail food license then
it would be under that program
thank you
other questions
okay
go ahead and Sherman McDonald thank you
very much uh Smith I'd like to invite up
at this time attorney Francesca
Hennessey
and the next section we're going to be
covering is section 10 of the bill and
that is found on page three lines 33
through Page four lines five and for
those of you who served on the committee
last session you'll recall that our
agency came before you to identify that
under a program and it's actually two
separate programs but they serve a very
similar purpose one is called the Mead
program uh and I know if chairman uh
over across the hall made a joke about
it being a beverage but in this case it
actually stands for Medicaid for
employed adults with disabilities and it
makes individuals who have certain uh
needs for accommodations uh much more
attractive from an employment standpoint
by employer because they can subject to
some income eligibility and also
clinical eligibility can receive
Medicaid so it does help offset the cost
for employer relative to medical
coverage so that's the bigger program
that's out there so this this isn't
about anything about the program other
than the fact that last session we came
before this group to identify that the
premiums paid by the individuals who
participate in these programs actually
our cost of trying to recover those fees
was close to being Awash in terms of an
impact to the state so it made sense at
that point that this is such an
important program to go ahead and
eliminate the premium fees as it relates
to the Mead program the mode program
moad is for Medicaid for older adults
with disabilities it was recently passed
within about the past five or six years
identifying that as we're having an
aging population the meat program covers
from 18 to 64 years but the thought
would be we have folks that are working
well past 65 and folks who have
challenges and so they created the
Medicaid for the older adults with
disabilities and also that program
likewise the premiums were eliminated by
this body and signed into law by the
governor last year what this does is
additional cleanup with all thoughtful
legislation you always seem to fine when
you're doing your gardening that there's
other Provisions that touch upon that so
we just need to go through that and make
those adjustments to remove the outdated
references to either premiums or other
items that this group that the
legislature already took action on so I
don't know if you have questions for
myself or attorneys Hennessy
uh representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question
if I understand the Mead program
correctly and I'm not sure I do it's
it's a program that allows people to con
who are meet certain conditions who are
disabled to continue to receive Medicaid
after they would have otherwise been
financially ineligible because they've
started to working start working so I'm
very interested in this because I think
it's a real problem
um that in some cases people are
don't have the incentive to work more or
get a higher paid job because they're
going to lose health insurance and so
they're going to lose
um
overall it's going to be a losing
proposition so my question is how long
can someone stay on the Mead program
once they've gone past Financial
eligibility and
um
and also I know this is not relative to
the bill itself but also how successful
is it in terms of encouraging people who
are disabled to
get jobs work and
um
be more ambitious in that area of their
life
right I mean what I will say to your
question is let's make it makes it much
easier for people to obtain this program
because there are no premiums anymore
that was done last session this is
simply a cleanup to take that out of the
rest of the bill I don't know of how
long a person can stay on I can
certainly get back to you on that I also
consult with more of our policy
in Medicaid to see if they have
measurables on the success of the
program that's a really good question I
just don't know this at this time
okay I'd appreciate anything I'll write
down your name so I can get back to you
representative Weber did you have a
question
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question I'm just making
sure that this is only about section 10
is that right and we're going to deal
with Section 11 differently or is
section 11
included in this particular yeah my
apologies if I did not make it clear
we're just right now on Section 10 of
the bill in the accepted Instinct
heading into section 11. I'm sure you
did but I was writing something else so
thank you any other questions
okay thank you
and that takes us to section 11 of the
uh section 11 of the bill
um and so I'm going to turn this over to
um attorney Hennessy to give you the
overview but uh this uh okay well let me
just slow up a bit okay here we go this
these sections of laws that we're going
to touch upon both sections 10 and also
um upgrad strike that 11 and 12. uh do
touch upon our supplemental nutrition
assistance program and so working along
with the New Hampshire legal assistance
we thought we did amend the bill in the
Senate to reflect that no longer is a
program referred to as food stamps
that's just the Vestige of the fact that
this statute hasn't been amended in
large measure since the mid 90s and so
we're here today essentially on both of
those two sections to do something very
simple which is to align under state law
the federal law as it relates to
overpayments in other words if an agency
overpays the amount of um that you're to
receive for the supplemental nutritions
program there is a process already in
place in law but we just want to make
sure that our state law is aligned with
with the federal law it's one of the
requirements that we have with what they
call the federal nutrition services
program uh FNS is another acronym that's
out there that you might be hearing us
talking about I know your your chair is
very familiar with all the subject
matter and perhaps would do a much
better job than myself in terms of
giving into the background but that's
essentially what we're trying to do is
to have it tie in with the provisions of
the federal laws that really so
overpayment in section 11 and in section
12 of the bill uh it's in terms of
disregards if we have individuals who
have been deemed not to do the right
things uh and three times I guess is not
the charm you're not doing the right
things that the disqualification pieces
of this also plan so that gets into the
area of safeguarding uh you know
valuable taxpayer dollars as it relates
to disqualifications and so we're
aligning also with federal law because
one of the best practices is is to make
a reference to the federal citations or
whatever it's a great practice of doing
that in in law the problem with that is
you can't see what those cfrs are so
certainly I'm looking to the venerable
members of your committee who might be
attorneys as well uh to also supplement
what we are providing here but we have
gone through the process to making sure
with great detail that the provisions
we're referring to here do refer back to
the correct Federal citations and law so
with that I'd like to turn it over to
fraternity uh Hennessey
terms of section 11 and 12. uh starting
with Section 11 we
this was a provision that we identified
um in going over our law in terms of
cleaning up what uh what our practices
and aligning that with the law of the
food and nutrition services are federal
oversight agency has approved a
particular claims management plan for us
and in that plan they have approved that
for any errors the department makes we
are required under federal law to
collect back that money however they
have allowed us to Simply make the
statement that if it's not more than 450
please don't go after it and so we
continue to do that we've always done
that the second section they've never
approved
um and we're we don't know that it is
approvable by FNS so we're taking out
the hard to measure recipients income
being less than or equal to two times
the federal poverty level it brought up
a lot of questions for us such as at
what time at what point in their life
are they under this federal poverty
level
um it was a it was a hard thing to
quantify in addition to it never being
approved by the federal government
um the second section section 12
um this is all federal law so under
seven CFR section
273.16 these are the current
disqualification penalties and John's
right three times is the charm if you
um are overpaid as representative
McDonald knows after three times and you
did that on purpose we're not you are
not no longer eligible for food stamps
and that has never changed what has
changed is that they have up the
disqualification penalties and we're
thank you
I think it was the um
back in 96 when as far back as that but
that was changed right to 12 and any I
think any claims prior to 96 was 6 12
and permanent then it went up after the
96 welfare reform Act
yeah thank you I wasn't exactly sure but
um it it is long overdue for being
updated so thank you I remember the new
Statue of books we get every year when I
was at the department they still said 6
12 and permanent so and it may confuse
judges where these cases are going
before yes thank you representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman so I don't
have it in front of me RSA 167
17-b is that the section in State
Statute that spells out
um
it is the violation and the penalty yes
and the violation is accepting more
snap
um
benefits
ah
yes if you have been receiving SNAP
benefits and you are convicted under
167.17b
um your first violation you will be
disqualified for
in the updated Lot 12 months your second
time you do that it's 24 months
um and after that it's permanently so
you do need a conviction so it would
have to be intentional
intentional violation so that assumes
it's something that the consumer did to
get more benefits than they should have
that it wasn't just a a never on the
part of the state yes thank you
important clarification between the two
statutes the first one I mentioned was
just errors on behalf of the department
this section is intentional violations
on the part of the recipient thank you
and there's also agents there's also
Plein error claims that can be collected
still right but no yes absolutely
representative Weber did you have a
question
it's been clarified thank you okay
any other questions
thank you and chairman McDonald that
takes us to the final coupling of
sections and I want to invite up at this
time Miss Danielle Hernandez she is an
administrator with the Department's uh
um division for public health services
and she is here in her capacity as
administrator with our State Office of
rural Health she does incredible work
particularly for underserved regions
within the state and this is a request
from the Department to take a reporting
requirement that we currently have from
an annual basis all the way to making it
a three-year reporting requirement and
this comes with the endorsement of the
underlying commission that actually
looks at primary care and Workforce
issues and at their January 25th meeting
if that's a Thursday which I believe it
is they actually formally voted and
approved these sections of the bill
recognizing the importance of the work
but that the frequency of the
information certainly based upon the
good works that are done that a
three-year cycle is is helpful there are
additional reporting requirements that
the State Office of rural Health has to
make on an annual basis in addition to
this so I would just turn it over to Mr
Hernandez who does an amazing job in her
capacity as administrator with our State
Office of rural health
thank you
um what we're asking is really just to
separate two fundamentally different
reporting requirements when legislation
passed on health Workforce data
collection what it did was required an
annual report to be incorporated into
this health disparities report and so
really what we want to do is because
they're so different we want to separate
them out so that it makes it easier for
stakeholders like yourselves to find the
information you're really looking for
instead of you know scouring through a
50 you know 50 plus page report to find
you know Health disparities information
by geography or primary care supply and
data collection efforts work and also
what this would do is give consideration
to limited staff resources for multiple
offices this takes a better part of
about half a year to put together to
coordinate to compile statistics for um
and it would also allow for a consistent
reporting of measures and current
estimates where we don't currently have
that because the data isn't collected
annually or analyzed by the respective
office annually so often
um the data in the annual reports for uh
the health status of rural residents
will be unchanged or even excluded so we
know that changes in health status are
incremental right they happen they very
rarely happen year to year so we know
that we wouldn't be limiting our you
know knowledge our understanding of
Health disparities in the state if we
change it to a three-year reporting
cycle the health statistics that we have
seen changed it's only because of the
change of a survey tool or you know the
analysis methodology it's not because
our actual changes in the health between
populations in the state
and just for a point of reference that
these um changes for the three-year
reporting requirement are found in
sections 13 and 14 of the legislation
found on page for line 25 through page
five line nine uh and if there's no
questions on this section that takes us
the last two sections of the bills that
are coupled together which are sections
uh 15 and 16. this is a question I'm
sorry I'm trying thank you Mr chairman
yeah nice try
um I I thank you I just had a how do I
access this data the report
yes so the report is actually published
on the DHHS website on the rural health
and Primary Care uh page we also present
the report to the HHS oversight
committee which is scheduled for the end
of the month of this month
um yeah so uh but the information is
always available and I think you will
find if you do locate that report I can
certainly send it over to you as well
but it is difficult to be able to find
um you know the information depending
again are you looking for a primary
Supply statistics are you looking for
our health Workforce efforts or are you
looking for health disparities
information it is sort of hard to locate
the information the report because it's
all gone together oh okay all right
thank you representative Plaza
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh maybe I'm missing
something but help me understand like
this speech from another report to have
this idea because sometimes things
happen uh fast and we want to know
what's going on like three years ago
maybe there was no covet pandemic so if
we would go and wait for three years
until the report we would miss some
important information
so um I I want to clarify that they're
one of the reports on for the health
Workforce data collection and that's the
primary care supply piece that of course
is you know important to track uh the
trends of annual Aid that would still be
required to be reported on annually so
that's the intent here
um the report the initial report that
has been a statutory requirement since
2009 on health disparities by geography
basically health status of rural
residence would change to every three
years so it's really just separating out
that report one the one that you know we
really do want to have our eyes on and
report on annually is going to stay as
an annual submission the other is going
to be every three years
um because we found that since reporting
there really hasn't been any incremental
changes and
um or excuse me there are very slight
incremental changes and when that does
happen it's you know it spends really
five years or so
um and we know we wouldn't be losing any
information limiting any of information
that's necessary for for State policy
and work
other questions
okay thank you and uh Miss Rogers I was
going to call up next uh had to leave
for another hearing in the Senate HHS
but we are loyal to this committee and
Ms Hernandez is going to stick with me
because it also involves Public Health
uh the sections 15 and 16 of the bill
were made as an accommodation a request
by Senator Apprentice who serves on the
and if we can look at the title together
because it's a very long title it is the
commission
um uh on um we're here we'll start right
over here here we go commission to study
the delivery of Public Health Services
in New Hampshire through Regional public
health networks and all this is doing is
extending the sunset provision for this
year for an additional year to allow
them to do their important work and I
didn't know if Miss Hernandez has any
underlying subject matter knowledge as
it relates to to this but otherwise we
were fine with this bill being used as a
vehicle for those two sections
and chairman McDonald if there's no
question that completes the Department's
presentation on Senate Bill 127. okay I
see no uh I see no questions so I want
to thank you and all your committee
members for your patience and us getting
through otherwise what would have been
eight different uh legislative hearings
so we appreciate that and thank you very
much for your thoughtfulness and your
consideration of this Bill thank you
thank you and thank you all for coming
today
they also signed up to speak as
representative Jess Edwards from
thank you Mr chair uh committee members
I'm uh representing Jess Edwards
representing Rockingham District
district 31 that's Auburn Candia Chester
and Deerfield since redistricting I have
to keep practicing that that's why I say
it but I'm also here today
fulfilling part of my duties as the
chairman of division three I'm looking
at house bill or Senate Bill 127 FN and
I notice there are some things in here
that might have been hb2 kind of items
or proposals either from the governor or
something brought to US during the
hospital two phase that that did not
come over to us so I wanted to just
comment on it first I'd say that most of
the experienced Representatives when you
first saw this bill I hope you thought
as I did oh no it's a Christmas tree
there's the problem with Christmas tree
bills when you identify a bunch of items
in one bill it really gets to be hard to
draw focus and get the right witnesses
to talk about each specific item things
go kind of quickly and I it's just a
process that makes me nervous that we
might Overlook something
so specifically on page one
um of
the bill lines three through
18. it it there's a policy issue here
where we want to take opioid we want to
establish fees for the opiate treatment
programs and we want to put those into
dedicated funds and we don't want them
to be deposited into the general fund
and and and I would just tell you that
uh as as somebody who looks at the
budget a lot these kinds of things
reduce the legislative Authority that I
think we have under our constitution to
pay attention to how money is getting
spent so as a general principle putting
money of taking it out of the general
fund and putting it into a dedicated
fund I think is a policy issue that I I
don't particularly like and there needs
to be a high threshold before we do that
kind of thing of why that's really
necessary and then I I think there may
be sort of some missing math here if you
if you look at page five or excuse me
line five into line six it says if the
provider had no clients in the previous
calendar year then the fee shall be a
thousand dollars
okay so what if they only had one
patient then according to that section
they would have to pay eight dollars
so I I think what this is attempting to
do is to say the minimum amount that any
provider must pay is at least a thousand
dollars plus eight dollars per patient
and so so that's a that's a policy
question whether or not it makes sense
but I just think we missed part of the
math there
otherwise it wouldn't make any sense if
I were a provider and I didn't have any
patience in December I would go
pay somebody five hundred dollars to be
my patient then I'd only have to pay an
eight dollar fee and I'd still make a
lot of money so it just it's just not
um good math
then
I I don't know this to be true and if
this comes over to division three I'll
I'll be asking questions about this
on pages four lines 25 down
talking about reports for the office of
rural health I I would I I asked the
question is this redundant and and I
wonder if it's redundant because we have
a dedicated office called Health Equity
Health Equity has seven ftes in it I
think we appropriated like 2.4 million
dollars for it and one of their roles is
to
take a look overall at the distribution
of clinical care around the state and to
make recommendations if there are
shortages particularly if there are
problems that we can associate with it
we we have all kinds of groups running
around right now trying to deal with our
Workforce issues so so I would just say
that this section 13 and maybe 14 I'd
have to look at a little bit more maybe
redundant and perhaps there there are
more questions still to be asked to make
sure that we're not duplicating efforts
so
that's it okay thank you questions for
representative Edwards
oh the representative that
representative Edwards raised demeanor
sure
specifically I was wondering about
um
representative Edwards catching the math
um issue which
um makes sense to me so
Tony Williams can you help us with this
or
there are two things you don't do on a
legislation like this you don't say a
word that I'm not going to say although
Summer Staff did use the word clean up I
think um and the other one is definitely
making sure you contact all the right
people in advance and certainly
recognizing Edwards leadership um it
needs to be applauded for the work that
he's done on behalf of New Hampshire
citizens and also uh here at the
legislature with that said what I want
to bring to your attention on sections
one and two of the bill but this body
and I think it was part of my original
testimony to the committee was actually
passed last session as part of HB 1661
originally it was in the department
requested bill which was Senate Bill 430
but that bill got held up in the process
and then eventually through the
committee conference process it was uh
it was added in advance of the process
to um HP 1661 so in terms of an
articulation of the policy both the
Senate and the house has already acted
on the underlying policy relative to
creating this fund for the opioid
enjoyed treatment programs those that
was already on the books all what was
being attempted to be done with this is
reflected in the physical analysis of
the bill was to clean up an incorrect
statutory reference originally it made
reference back to the fund itself and
the fees that are being collected are
not in that same statute they're in the
controlled Drug Act and that is where
those fees are being collected so again
it was correcting a incorrect
cross-reference to where those fees were
located but the underlying policy was
passed by the legislature this um this
past session in HP 1661. with that I
always have to recognize that new eyes
can look and have further conversations
but it is something that we weren't
trying to do anything different than
wasn't already passed by the legislature
last year
so if I'm hearing you correctly that
explains the origin of the dedicated
fund
um whether or not we agree with it uh
but the question about the math
is still unresolved and I was wondering
if anybody I think representative
Shapiro also asked this if anybody could
speak to the issue of if you have one
client you pay uh eight dollars
and if you have zero clients you pay a
thousand dollars and I'm actually
wondering why if you have no clients for
an entire year you're paying a fee of a
thousand dollars in any case uh and I I
think clarification would be very
helpful on that yeah so just so folks
understand that the fee structure here
has been placed in in statute and I
believe also adopted through
administrative rules so what you're
talking about is an existing law this is
not a new provision of law in terms of
the funding mix should that be
re-examined again I leave that question
open for others to look at but what I
could represent to the committee is that
um the sums of money we're looking at
are total fees collected range anywhere
between the upper thirty thousand uh
dollar range annually to around forty
thousand dollars around Ball parking but
I can get you specific and also
represent Edward specific uh fees from
our financial managers around that we're
not looking at a large sum of money but
it isn't important to support the
important efforts around opioid
treatment prevention and the the the
identification of any issues are in
existing law it's not anything we're
attempting to do with this legislation
right I follow I get that I just I would
be more
um
I would be happier in my mind if if it
was explained to us with more details so
we understand
what we're looking at understood like
because I agree on the the words that we
have here
do imply
um
an oddity and I certainly can get back
to the committee with a further
explanation on the number of programs
that we actually oversee how the
breakdown Works in terms of each
individual program and the payments that
they make to us and and once you get
that information that data it may make
more sense once you see it I can just
give you the derivative which is the
cumulative fees that we we do see from
these programs range anywhere between
the upper thirty thousand to around
forty thousand dollars uh in 2022 so our
snapshot looking at about a three-year
perspective retroactively but certainly
we'll follow up with the committee uh
and also with Edwards uh with more
detail around that okay representative
Nagel and then representative Seth King
I kind of had my hand halfway up but I
do want to ask the question this is
really more of a policy issue but I'm
like totally blurry-eyed now from moving
really reviewing a lot of policy
statements about the tenure mental
health program the
um uh the drug abuse all the governor's
um task forces on these things and one
of the statements that's made over and
over and over again is about our
deficiency in terms of medication
assisted therapies access to methadone
treatments and things like that and I'm
really struggling with the concept of
actually having these groups pay us
money when I think we are desperate and
we should be paying other people money
to subsidizing them to provide the
service so I'm lost why we're even
charging them at all
um that's a statement that's policy
statement that's probably I know is not
reflected in this bill but since it was
brought up I thought I should bring it
up and chairman uh if I can just address
briefly represent Nagel
um that those have already been
articulated by the legislature uh the
legislature you this body and the Senate
that body and the governor whoever
signed off established that policy prior
to us coming here today on the bill and
certainly I think getting the data under
understanding is going to be helpful uh
we certainly think supporting those
medication and treatment programs are
very very important as well and we also
think that supporting our efforts and
our agency which was already passed last
session in HB 1661 to allow that model
to support our efforts to supporting
those programs would be particularly
helpful and all we're trying to do is
correct the cross-reference to the
correct funding mechanism in this
legislation
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chairman I hope I'm not speaking um out
of line here but I think this makes
perfect sense to me the thousand dollars
every provider at some point wasn't a
provider and this is basically just a
startup fee it's like imagine joining a
gym uh your startup fee might be 300 new
and then it's thirty dollars a month
after that but if you've been a member
of the gym for the last 20 years you're
just paying 30 a month you don't need to
keep you don't ever have to pay that
three you were already kind of
grandfathered in so the thousand dollars
is just a startup fee so that's how I
understand it thank you thank you
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman
um in regard to um representative
Edwards last point about
um page four line 27.
um
the report on Health Equity being
changed to three every three years
um is that a redundancy or is that a
requirement of some of receiving some
kind of federal funds
and it could still be over redundancy
even if it is if I understood
representative uh representative Edwards
observations correctly and I'm going to
look back at him and he can shake his
head yes or no as I'm speaking that
would be helpful
um that in the presentation by the
department uh before division three
house finance we did agency
presentations that broke it down to
particular either offices or boroughs
within our agency one of the briefings
would have likely involved our office of
Health Equity and I think what
representative Edwards has identified is
an overlap between the mission and I'm I
don't want to be too broad the mission
of that entity within the department and
then branching over to the work that Ms
Hernandez and her folks do Under The
State Office of rural Health as an
agency we are always responsive to
looking at appropriate alignments and
I'm not in a position to articulating
anything because I'm not at that level
represent Edwards to make that happen
others could perhaps but for example in
the the area of homelessness in Housing
Services we recently transitioned that
Bureau that was under our division for
economic and housing stability which is
now called the division of economic
stability because we moved the housing
from that program and that program was
around other types of assistance and
supports that we provide to people like
the SNAP benefits and other kind of of
assistance that we provide we moved it
that program under homelessness and
housing to the division for Behavioral
Health and we did that because the
population being served in Behavioral
Health better aligned with the needs for
housing because you can't you can't you
know fully systemically treat people
unless during the process they have a
place to live when they're going out the
door you got to have something to
address coming in the door and something
coming out the door so our I do think
that there is a receptiveness to looking
at alignment issues and I think that
that's what representative Edwards on a
much higher level we were just asking
for a one year to three year change and
not a complete realignment of the
department but I do think I understood
what your observations were
close it's a question about potential
redundancy and then aligning the
missions of the work so we're not
funding the same thing twice
thank you other questions and if Mr
Hernandez she's actually going to give
you the the correct answer to
representative Edwards question and I
didn't know if representative Edwards
even wanted to be invited I'm happy to
all right I just wanted to expound on
that
um that yes the State Office of rural
Health under rural health and Primary
Care in the state
um is established as the soar in statute
since 2009 we're actually
um almost the soar is exclusively funded
by hersa by a grant under under hersa so
while this report is a statutory
oh the health services and Health
Resources and services Administration
excuse me
um so although this is a statutory
requirement to provide this report
um it's just one of several activities
that is conducted under Federal funding
thank you
so you know other questions
good thank you thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 127 does anyone else wish
to testify
saying no one else I'm going to close
the public hearing on Senate bill 127.
thank you all for your testimony
and I am going to open the public
hearing on Senate bill 200. and
recognize the prime sponsor who is
thank you Mr chairman for the record I'm
Cindy Rosenwald I represents Senate
District 13 which is most of Nashua and
I'm very pleased to introduce Senate
Bill 200 which will open up another
means to make certain vaccines more
conveniently accessible and at lower
costs to Consumers it does so by
allowing optometrists to administer
influenza kovid and shingles vaccines to
adults
optometrists or doctoral Level Health
Care providers who are highly
experienced in sterile techniques they
are represented here today and they can
explain why this bill is good idea from
their perspective I just say that we
have allowed people to get vaccines in
pharmacies from a variety of different
licensing levels of Pharmacy
employees for 15 years it's worked
really well it's less expensive for
people and it's very very convenient
so from my perspective consumers will
save money on these three vaccines
because just as at a pharmacy they won't
need to pay a separate copay if they're
already at the optometrist office so if
they went to their physician to get
these vaccines they would have to pay a
copay
and these three vaccines I think make a
lot of sense
influenza and covid are recommended for
broad groups of adults and shingles is
recommended for people over 50. also
shingles is a disease that can have
devastating effects on Vision so makes
sense to me for optometrists
to administer shingles vaccines we
thought we had allowed optometrists to
administer covid vaccines during the
public health emergency but it turns out
we will need to make a statutory change
I hope the committee will look favorably
on this bill and I'm happy to answer
questions thank you Senator Senator
thank you Mr chairman and welcome back
Senator
um yeah
my question is
about record keeping
people have gotten used to
um
medical records being kept at Physician
Offices or primary care provider offices
they're also now used to record keeping
at pharmacies
an initial glance of that is is that
although although the the shingles
um connection seems pretty intuitive to
me the other two are kind of
counter-intuitive Could you
um talk a little bit about record
keeping and how people as the places
that you can get
uh vaccinated
become more and more diffuse how people
appropriately access their records to
know when they need to get shots and
when uh they're overdue or when they
shouldn't be getting shots
well
if you look at them starting on page one
of the Bell line 29.
this would require the optometrist to
check the vaccine okay registry ahead of
time and then record
the vaccine
Administration and the registry unless
the individual opt-out but if your
question is how does just random me know
that I need a shingles vaccine I think
it's helpful when a provider says have
you had a shingles vaccine and I
probably would say I
can't remember but they would be able to
check the vaccine registry unless I had
opted out okay they would be able to say
we've already had it you're all set or
you haven't had it yeah you're over 50.
you should have it because shingles can
make you go blind right and I well I I
just thank you for the question and
apologize for not having done my
homework a little better
not necessary representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question would you envision
maybe this would be better directed
towards
um optometrists but would you envision
that this being a kind of a sideline for
optometrists where there would be
advertising that these vaccines were
available at optometrist's office or do
you envision it more as in the course of
getting your eyes checked that you would
be asked about and reminded that these
are good things to do and that they're
available at that very office
that's a really interesting question
personally I think not that many
optometrists would do it because
um there's record keeping
you for covid vaccines anyway you need
that super cold storage
um
I don't know that very many of them
would make a business decision that what
they would get reimbursed was worth the
time and expense
of doing it so I think maybe some very
large practices might decide and I think
you're going to hear from from one of
them after me that this is a service
that if they have if they put eye drops
in somebody's eye and then the patient
is sitting around for 15 or 20 minutes
that it would be an opportunity while
they're in the office to have that
conversation
and then do this other service I don't
think it would be broadly adopted I
might be wrong but just looking at
that the effort and the expense that
goes into stocking these things and the
paperwork I'd be surprised if that many
practices
decided it was worth it we do have
someone signed up from the New Hampshire
Optometric Association we'll be
testifying so
but for sure go ahead I would just as
someone who just uh a week ago or so got
my shingles vaccine
um you're so young
thank you and um and having put it off
for many many years so I'm not that
young and in part that it just became
free but also that um you know they
didn't have it at my doctor's office for
whatever reason so
um I put it off for
decades I guess and um had I been
someplace where someone said oh if you
want that we can just give it to you I
probably would have done it a long time
ago and um it would have been safer
well I'm glad you didn't get shingles in
the meantime
another question just representative
King thank you Mr chairman thank you
senator for taking questions
um I'm Reed I don't have the full RSA
that's being amended in front of me I
apologize but um
um I'm reading this year and I see that
they can currently apply topicals and
oral medications are there currently any
um vaccines that optometrists can can
currently you know use subcutaneous
injections for like or is or is this
going to be opening it up to a whole new
section of things that they can do thank
you I think probably
one of the optometrists could better
answer that question I'm going to say I
think they can't but
they'll be able to give you a better
response
other questions representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thank you Senator
um to me there's three important
questions involved in this bill
um the first is
and you don't need to answer the third
one's the one that's most important but
like why
uh why are we doing this secondly are
they qualified but thirdly which is most
important to me from a public health
point of view obviously access is
important I think we did demonstrate we
were pretty accessible to a broad
pandemic is this absolutely necessary to
increase success accessibility and is
absolutely necessary
I think you'll hear
from some of these optometrists that
they are
a provider that somebody sees even when
I hate to say this to you they don't go
see their physician so sometimes they're
the only provider that someone sees and
let me just say that in my own family my
53 year old nephew
hadn't seen a doctor in 10 or 15 years
but does regularly see the optometrist
because his
his vision needs change so
it I know already one person who only
um let's let me also just try to answer
your other question about are they the
that allows pharmacies to
um give a way bigger range of vaccines
we allow pharmacy technicians Pharmacy
interns not just pharmacists so not just
the doctoral level
person but people under their
supervision who I think have a lot less
education and experience than a doctoral
level
optometrist who is well versed in in
sterile technique
so I think they're capable
but wonderful answers what do I know
thank you
thank you other questions uh yes
representative Palazzo thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
questions Senator uh what was the logic
uh to footage limitations in this bill
about 18 years old so
um
we allow pharmacies and have for 15
years to give a broad range of
vaccinations only to adults
um
when I
asked the state's chief medical officer
Dr Ballard
about the other bill then I think you
heard the RSV vaccine
he said we want to make sure that
children are still
getting their vaccinations within their
Pediatric Care settings because there's
a lot of
other
care
and counseling and thought
that goes into it so
um
there's
not
thinking among the medical
establishment of the state that it's a
good idea for children and we have not
allowed children to receive vaccines in
pharmacies over the 15 years so this is
consistent
with that statute and I personally think
it's appropriate
representative King thank you Mr
chairman and thank you again for taking
another one of my questions as the
crafter of the bill why did you only
include those three vaccines why not
just open it up to everything thank you
okay that's a great question
first of all we don't
open it up to everything in pharmacies
um and this question has come up because
most states do allow pharmacies to
administer any vaccine that's authorized
by the FDA we don't here's why I think
that's appropriate
there are some vaccines that are given
to very to smaller groups of adults
based on their specific
travel plans or their social habits or
their medical history
um and so I think if we're going to open
up
all vaccines I think it's going to
result in some people getting
vaccinations that they really don't need
and it's going to add expense
unnecessary expense to the Health Care
System overall because these vaccines
you might get them without a copay
but there's cost
to your health insurer so so I think the
I'm an incremental kind of a gal
and this is a new scope of practice for
optometrists these are three vaccines
that as as I said are given to Broad
groups
of people you don't need
you no need to know if the person is
traveling to you know this part of
Panama not that part of Panama or
whether they're sexual habits make them
someone who should get a monkey box
vaccine it's just basically oh you're an
adult have you had your flu shot this
year no one in
so so that's why I just think it's
prudent
say no other questions okay thank you so
much I'm sorry I can't stay no that's
also signed up to speak is Dr Angelique
Sawyer from the New Hampshire Optometric
Association
good morning good morning um a special
thank you to Senator Rosenwald for her
time and for answering all of those
questions
um I have some thoughts and words I'd
like to share but then I do invite you
if any of those questions were not fully
addressed by her or any others please
um I'm happy to answer those
um my name is Dr Angelique Sawyer I am a
New Hampshire native and a practicing
doctor of Optometry in our rural North
Country with offices in both North
Conway and Berlin New Hampshire
I thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today in support of Senate Bill
200 a bill that seeks to accomplish two
goals to authorize Doctors of Optometry
to administer vaccines and to allow
Doctors of Optometry to prescribe
medications for the treatment of the
lacrimal gland
first some background Doctors of
Optometry do not simply prescribe
glasses and contact lenses to correct
vision as was the case well over 50
years ago
since the 1970s Doctors of Optometry
have been prescribing medication for the
treatment of disease
we are recognized federally by CMS as
independent Physicians
while our focus is on treatment of the
eye and visual system we understand
assess and educate our patients on how
the entire body impacts their Eye Health
all day long I discussed with my
patients not only their diabetes but
their rheumatoid arthritis their thyroid
disease their shingles and how those
conditions impact their eyes and their
vision
next I'll speak briefly about the
lacrimal gland restriction that this
bill would address since 1993 Doctors of
Optometry in the state of New Hampshire
have been able to prescribe oral
medications for the treatment of all
anterior structures of the eye with the
exception of the lacrimal gland the
lacrimal gland is located in the upper
outer corner of the orbit produces the
watery layer of the tears if it becomes
inflamed and if it's due to an
infectious cause that infection can
spread leading to something that's
called orbital cellulitis that can be
vision and life-threatening
we are able to treat orbital orbital
cellulitis but we are not currently
allowed to treat the dacrio adenitis
that then may lead to that
um we have for uh for decades Doctors of
Optometry have been trained in the
diagnosis and treatment of lacrimal
gland infections by accredited colleges
of Optometry and in fact as I said we
can treat the the complications of but
not the precursors to prevent that
complication in these situations a delay
in treatment while referring to an
ophthalmologist is critical and um and
unnecessary when we have the training
and um uh and the ability to treat this
uh before more serious complications
develop
the second aspect of this bill is what
we've been talking primarily about is
the administering of the vaccinations
um during the height of the covid-19
pandemic when the governor issued
emergency orders to address the
immediate need for additional medical
trained Personnel to administer covid-19
vaccines Doctors of Optometry could not
be included because of our outdated
statute which strictly prohibited this
an independent doctorate level health
care provider was refused from providing
this aspect of care while individuals
with far less training were permitted
including medical assistance licensed
nurse practitioners dental hygienists
and pharmacy technicians
in New Hampshire if I have a high school
diploma or a GED I can administer
vaccines but if I've gone on to have
four years of college education and four
years of doctorate Level Training and
Optometry I'm now restricted from being
able to provide that care
this bill is not about doctors about
palmettry feeling left out during the
pandemic nor is it an opportunity for
generating Revenue as some may suggest
this bill is about removing Antiquated
restrictions in order to allow Doctors
of Optometry to use their training to
provide better quality and greater
access to care for our patients
we are We Are The Eye Care the primary
care provider for the eye we have many
patients who are in exam chairs more
often than in their Primary Care
provider's office
access to care is not just about
geographic location and travel distances
but also about patient convenience
patients who may be interested in
receiving a vaccine while in a
provider's office may not always take
the extra steps to make an appointment
and travel elsewhere to receive that
vaccine
the truth is that most Doctors of
Optometry are not planning to offer
vaccines in their offices at this time
but the landscape of Health Care is
changing and provider shortages are
increasing Doctors of Optometry should
not be restricted from providing care
that lesser trained individuals are
permitted to provide
this bill specifies just as with all
other medical professionals who
vaccinate that Doctors of Optometry will
be required to fulfill the appropriate
vaccine-specific requirements for
training Administration safety reporting
and Adverse Events
thank you for your time for serving our
patients and the citizens of New
Hampshire I ask that you please support
Senate Bill 200 I'm happy to answer any
questions
yes representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman um I have two questions one is
um
why not include the pneumococcal vaccine
which seems like a I don't really know
anything about vaccines but it seems
like a seasonal vaccine like like the
flu vaccine that's my first question and
second question is how well equipped are
not the doctorate level
um
not the doctorate level optometrists but
your office is equipped to deal with
immediate severe side effects should
those occur
absolutely
um so first in regards to the vaccines
um again it is similar to what you know
Dr Rosenwald said starting incrementally
um these are ones that uh we so
frequently and wide population range and
particularly in the case of shingles
that we're seeing the outcomes of it um
on a frequent basis we are certainly
open to including additional vaccines in
the future just as
um as she indicated even Pharmacy is
restricted as to which ones they they
provide
um as for training in the office our
we would not have other providers in our
office that would be administering the
vaccine that would be done by the doctor
of Optometry however we do train our
staff on all emergency situations we
offer CPR training to all of our staff
um we there we have um you know uh
crash kits not not crash car but we have
um medications throughout the office we
have um smelling salts they're all
prepared for if a patient is is you know
um
uh having syncope fainting the proper
way to respond to that patient to get
them in a safe situation and to have the
doctor of Optometry immediately
available
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh my question I guess in this
sense uh refers back to representative
Nagel's question is why now
um right now I understand that we have
about 98 percent coverage for vaccine
access uh for everybody in the state of
New Hampshire within 30 minutes or a 30
minute drive from their home
the pandemic has the emergency will be
lifted in May but also was told we were
told yesterday that for all intents and
purpose it's over at this point in time
the reason I asked that question is I
think sometimes patients get confused as
to what vaccines they've had how many
they've had the various types of
vaccines the vaccinations they have so
my question is why now why wasn't this
done and introduced two years ago at the
peak of the pandemic
um and as you may know that there are
multiple vaccines that are given with
covet you know there's a bivalent there
was the initial you know that is both
modern there's Pfizer
and my concern is that in the bill it
says that if a patient
um basically
when designated by the patient it's it's
allowed the primary care is notified of
getting a vaccine so my my concern also
is
that the um that the patient if they
have many areas many ear Avenues to get
these vaccines and they're not sure
which ones they got which one was a
bivalent which one was Modern versus
Pfizer versus JJ whomever the record
keeping in the accountability to the
primary care I think sometimes can be
potentially diluted and I'm just
concerned about them getting vaccines at
multiple different sites
understandable
um we would follow the same recording
reporting guidelines as with
um pharmacies we already probably to an
even greater extent do record sharing
with primary care offices we are very
frequently sending reports back and
forth when I'm beginning a topical
treatment that may interact with
somebody's other medications I'm making
sure that their provider knows new
medications that are that are being
added to them
um I would not treat a patient if I do
not have access to registry information
or their health care records and know
whether that is appropriate for them
that is part of the training and part of
the you know indication as to whether we
offer these and there are some
optometrists who may choose not to and
there are some optometrists who who uh
won't go through the training to be able
to do this but particularly where I'm
located
um 30 minutes is very far for somebody
to get to a provider many Primary Care
Providers uh are not available we have a
shortage in our area we have primary
care provider offices that have very
long wait lists to get in and so um this
is about being able to provide access
when we have the patients in front of us
this is about removing a restriction
that prevented us from being able to be
included even when there was an
emergency order and
we can't allow for just an emergency
order to address this in the future if
something were to come up this needs to
be fixed at this level so that when
things come up we're prepared to to
address that well thank you um you
mentioned that you do offer staff CPR
training yes is it mandated it is not at
the staff level for optometrists it is
for Doctors of Optometry it is yes it is
mandated for you to have CPR yes you
know okay and
how often how often does a patient come
into your office into an optometrist
because again it's foreign to me I
usually think of the CVS a pharmacist
the hospital the primary care how often
does a patient come into an
optometrist's office and say I would
like the coveted vaccine or the um the
flu vaccine or the shingles vaccine well
well right now never because they do not
they're not aware that we they're we're
not allowed to offer it
um we don't advertise that to the
question that was asked earlier I don't
think that that is going to be something
that we're promoting hey come here to
get your vaccine
um there are places where people are
seeking out their vaccines that they can
have that available to them if they are
if they do learn and this becomes
available and something that we can
offer and they seek it out to us
absolutely we would like to be able to
provide that
um but that's not why we're doing this
we're not doing this because people are
knocking down our doors and saying Hey I
want my vaccine why can't you give it to
me
um we are are trying to add to that
access for those patients that are there
in front of of us I have many patients
that I see every year I have many
patients that I see three four five
times a year I see shingles
very frequently and many of those
patients have not been seeing a primary
care provider have not had that
opportunity to have that vaccine and are
not thinking oh I need to go ask for
somebody to provide that so as part of
our Primary Care Service that we're
providing to our patients when we're
discussing their Total Eye Health that
question comes up have you had your
shingles vaccine no okay this is why
it's important and this is some of the
complications to your vision that can
happen from this oh that's great oh but
I have to go somewhere else to get it
well I don't have a primary care doctor
um you know the pharmacist sitting in
the hallway you know somebody that they
don't know my my history they don't you
know the the this technician does not
have the history with me that you have
as my eye care provider but that's not
something that we're able to offer you
at this time
representative Palazzo thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh it's uh first uh I wonder if
you in your practice or others uh
optometrist you are working with ever
dealt with vaccine adverse reaction or
considered it or reported it to
vaccine adverse reaction database files
and
the second part is like
what's my concern that uh I'm here from
other jurisdictions
for example uh from optometrists in
British islands that a very small
percentage of people who got covet
vaccines they have problems with vision
but when we got it to Absolute numbers
it's like hundreds people of people so
my concern is if
already have some hesitation to consider
a girl's reaction and Reporting like if
somebody is losing vision you probably
want asking them when when was your last
vaccination and now we will with this
bill we will have situation when
optometrist will be the person who
administered the vaccine and the
organization profited from them so then
they will be even more hesitation to
investigate and Report those reactions
so could you comment
um and I'm not quite sure if I followed
everything uh we we would absolutely be
held to the same responsibility for
reporting Adverse Events
um if I have a patient who has had an
adverse event and we determined that
they've recently had a vaccine and I am
currently on the receiving end of
treating an adverse event
um I
um
I typically work with their primary care
provider to address that event and to
discuss um you know the the relationship
there
um and work with that provider to report
that event because we do not currently
have access and the ability to do um all
of that directly
um
uh
apologize
um was there another question
um
doing over a single case when
optometrist in New Hampshire reported an
adverse vaccine election ever
right so I I would understand that no I
don't believe that there is a case that
that has been reported to date
um there may be in other states where
other states where optometrists are
providing vaccines
um there has been no increase in
malpractice or liability rates in other
states where optometrists are providing
vaccines
um there has been no increase in Adverse
Events in those States
representative King thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking questions
the sponsor of the bill seemed to be
under the belief that very few
optometrists really would take advantage
of this and and offer vaccines in my
mind's eye I imagine places like you
know Dartmouth health and search you
know certain places that offer a lot of
different Services
um probably would maybe take advantage
of that
um in your opinion who do you think
would really take advantage of this this
new law do you think it would be a lot
of optometrists or would it be more of
the larger providers thank you thank you
um it would be primarily the larger
providers in fact we do have one
prepared to speak after me who would
plan to offer that in their office as
they have multiple providers multiple
locations where I am located
um it is something that I would like to
be able to do because I am in such a
rural location and access to care is so
critical for my patients I do not have
the facilities right now to be able to
do that and that is something that I'm
working to address that as we grow I
would like to be able to do that
um and I I think that it's
um it's not prudent to just kick it down
the road until I'm personally ready to
offer that in my office there are
offices that are available and able to
do it now
okay
I'm seeing no other questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Scott Huffer
oh and Dr Sawyer could you give us a
copy of your testimony
sorry
it says to wipe down the microphone but
there's nothing to wipe it down with oh
um
do we have anything Christina any wipes
you're welcome to sit down if you want
sure sorry to be difficult no no that's
fine
you know the first person who's actually
raised that issue so but oh you did okay
okay
good morning good morning good morning
uh committee members and Mr chairman
thank you uh for hearing me today um my
name is Scott Huffer I'm an eye doctor
and one-third owner of focused Eye Care
with offices in Nashua and Milford New
Hampshire I am the immediate past
president of the New Hampshire
Optometric Association the nhoa
and a fellow of the American Academy of
Optometry and a residency trained doctor
of Optometry
focused Eye Care currently employs seven
full-time doctors and another 38
approximately support staff members
last year our providers provided care
for 12 470 people suffice to say we
provided Eric Eye Care to a lot of
individuals
in my experience it is very common to
see patients who have not seen their
primary care doctors in many years I
also see patients daily who have not do
not have a primary care physician due to
Providers retiring relocating or the
patient simply neglected to select to
find one
I frequently see patients who report not
having flu covet and shingles vaccines
despite it being in their best interest
the shingles vaccination is probably the
most notable a shingles can cause
temporary and permanent vision loss when
involving the eye
ideally these patients would receive
these vaccinations but Public Health
Data tells us that they are not doing so
the shingles vaccination is about around
for many years is well tested in adults
50 to 69 years old with healthy immune
systems this vaccine was 97 effective in
preventing shingles an adult 70 years
older and older it was 91 effective this
is a vaccine success story but only
about 30 percent of adults who might
benefit from this have received it and
one in three adults over the age of 50
will get the disease
this is just one example of how adding
another well-trained group of doctors
into the mix of providers will help the
state of New Hampshire improve health
outcomes our patients come to see us as
a matter of need so they can see to work
and live better we regularly educate
them on smoking cessation the important
of vaccines and other important
preventative measures so it only makes
sense that we could offer this if a
patient is ready to do so
optometrists could also be a critical
component of increasing vaccination
rates and decreasing disease burden
across the state
Doctors of Optometry are fully capable
of Performing vaccinations
intravenous and intramuscular injections
are part of the curriculum at every
optometry school across the country an
injection certification is an optional
part of the national board of exam for
optometrists optometrists are currently
authorized to perform injections in 22
States
I'm sure the biggest question anyone
would have would be what happens if a
patient patient suffers a severe
allergic anaphylactic reaction
but emergency preparation is a critical
process in all offices in our office we
have always maintained emergency
medications and automated defibrillator
all of our providers are required to
maintain CPR training and emergency
training because it's required for
licensed training we also provide
in-house CPR training for all our staff
it is not currently mandated but will
continue to consider that in the future
just like any doctor's office or
Pharmacy where vaccines are administered
we too rely on the emergency management
system for otherwise more serious events
luckily this is very rare anaphylaxis
rate for coveted vaccination is 11 per 1
million individuals and for flu
vaccinations it's 1.35 per million
individuals
recently in our office our preparation
was tested we had a patient suffer a
severe seizure in our waiting room and
our staff handled the situation
perfectly and appropriately uh
as we as we expected and as we are all
trained so in summation authorizing
optometrists to provide vaccinations
could safely increase vaccination rates
and prevent significant disease across
the population of New Hampshire
thank you could we get a copy of your
written testimony please absolute
questions
yes representative Nagel
um I want to ask the same question I'll
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question the same question that was
asked of Senator Rosenwald but why just
these three
I would love to administer more we had
to work with our sponsors and and I
believe incremental changes is
appropriate so I believe in the future
we'll show our Merit and increase those
those uh to more and other vaccinations
but um I realize this is a new uh change
and and change comes low so incremental
changes is progress as far as I'm
concerned so we'll take what we can get
all right thank you
representative Murphy great thank you
very much and thanks for taking my
question Mike my question would be have
you estimated what the what the cost
would be for an office to set up for say
covid vaccines or any other vaccines and
the reason I ask that is oftentimes
if you look at other you know services
offered we think about the the concept
of a certificate of need so that it's
absolutely necessary in a certain area
otherwise you're incurring increased
cost to your practice which then can be
transferred to a patient so when I think
about setting it up in the office
there's a refrigeration this is a
training of staff there is the reporting
there I mean so time is money also so
I'm trying to understand what the cost
would be how would this affect patients
how would this be transferred to a
patient especially in light of the fact
that the majority of patients in the or
people in the state have access to the
covid flu and
other vaccines currently available
there's a lot in that so have I done a
cost benefit analysis quick quick and
dirty not completely things like
refrigeration and record keeping are
things that happen every day in our
office we have lots of things that need
to be refrigerated and some are frozen
um you know so that is something we deal
with on a daily basis and that would not
apply any incurred costs if anything
this is uh something that we're already
doing it would be an incremental
addition
so as far as cost of vaccination no I I
not being able to administer
vaccinations I'm not able to really
appropriately look into the cost we are
a large office we have many resources I
don't see it being a huge impediment
but if we are authorized I can be sure
we'll make it happen
and representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking the question
in regards to looking through this from
the eyes of a business venture
can you speak to how the office is going
to handle
shingles vaccines my understanding is
most of them are built to the pharmacy
benefits signed through a PBM I know on
a Part D that's exactly where they have
to go because that's where a lot of
patients end up in the pharmacy is
because of the fact that they have to be
billed by the pharmacy or Bill to the
pvm side of the equation
can you speak to that as far as
with optometrists in the office and the
Billing System you can have in place
that you can be able to bill the
insurance company for it and not charge
the patient for it and then have the
patient try to get reimbursed by the
insurance company
I can say we currently bill for all
sorts of different medical services
and having it's always a challenge
building for any medical services it
does get complicated as we co-manage
after surgical procedures in regards to
cataracts and those rare occasions
classes can be covered by medical
insurance so it's not new territory as
far as building medical insurance goes
we haven't been able to bill for
vaccinations so it'll be a learning
curve for sure
that follow-up yeah
yes it will be the reason I'm trying to
bring this up is to be sure that I'm
trying to protect the patient from them
being charged by the optometrist and
then the honest is on them to try to get
back reimbursement from the insurance
companies because vaccines specifically
most of them are built on the part D not
which is a pharmacy benefit not a
medical benefit so I want to make sure
that the Optometry Community understands
that the billing process is
fundamentally different and I just want
to be sure that the patient ultimately
is not the person going to be charged
for it it does go back to the billing
process and the accomplishers will take
care of that yeah I I can assure you
that in my office we wouldn't plan on
balance billing anyone but you know we
do this daily there are procedures that
we expect to be covered that aren't most
of the time it's not permitted to
balance bill in our industry
representative Palmer
so this is related to representative
Merchants thank you for
Mr chairman thank you for taking a
question
I always forget to say that sorry okay
so um I just had my shingles vaccine and
I had gone in to see my primary care
physician I'm lucky enough to have one
um
and um
he said have you had the new shingles
act no uh and I said okay and I then I
was waiting for the nurse to come back
and it said no they it it's exactly what
representative Merchant said is that for
that office which is in a you know it's
in a big Clinic to
um provide the vaccine it's it's not
financially reasonable for them to do
that so they just give me a prescription
to go down to Rite Aid and so my
question to you is
um would that be something you would be
able to do in in that instance if it's
going to be an insurance issue
um just prescribe the medication so the
patient can go and get their vaccine the
um representative Palmer my
understanding is they can administer it
but they cannot prescribe for it unless
it's through their formulary so I do
understand where you're going it makes a
lot of sense but the way this is written
they can only administer the vaccine
they cannot prescribe the vaccine to be
given by somebody else
or
yes
representative Weber
sorry
thank you so and thank you for taking my
questions so I'll I'll put the ball back
in your court
um it's my understanding that
um
my optometrist prescribes medications
for me regularly
um
my optometrist is cited in Vermont
rather than New Hampshire do New
Hampshire optometrists not have the
ability to prescribe or do they
currently have the the ability to
prescribe some medications but not these
and clearly clearly uh we're solving an
issue with prescribing with regard to
the lack of local program planned here
so if you could explain to us what the
current status is of prescribing
Authority for optometrists here that
would be helpful
so
yes we do prescribe medications topical
and oral on a daily basis that affect
the eyes with some limitations
so uh I do not have the whole statue
right in front of me but I can tell you
on a daily basis I write probably eight
to ten prescriptions every single day
for oral or topical medications
the lacrimal glanda was a previous
exclusion hopefully we hope to have that
going forward but I believe it's
anything that's reasonable to treat the
eye and surrounding tissue
well
so I just wanted to explore a little bit
more about this question about is it
preferable
sorry is it preferable
to have for an optometrist to be able to
administer
the vaccine or to be able to prescribe
the vaccine which could then be obtained
in a pharmacy or both
ah
preferable for both that said the point
of this bill is to offer it in office at
the time to administer the vaccination
to bring point of care to where the
patient is instead of the reverse I see
access as a care as a Continuum not an
absolute you know if we can meet the
patient where they are the access will
be better vaccines will be more
prevalent and disease will be prevented
which is what the hope of this bill is
so the opportunity to prescribe a
vaccination and have it later on I think
misses the point the point here is to
meet a patient where they are to have
the vaccine at the time because what
happens when we put something off it
doesn't happen
and when it doesn't happen across the
population people get ill and there's
burden and illness that could have been
prevented so
other questions
representative Palazzo thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh I'm interested how do you
see the legal framework especially
around current very aggressive
anti-vaccine hesitancy framework so
let's take a scenario that healthy 18
year old male comes to you and let's say
you know the Department of Health and
Human Services
know that this demographic is uh has
increased the risk of myocarditis after
covid-19 vaccine Administration and also
let's say you know that healthier 18
year old is probably has a very low risk
of severe covet and if you have risk
benefit analysis
and let's say as a doctor you think that
maybe that person don't need that
vaccine but would you be able to tell
that client that you don't need it
because like then you causing vaccine
hesitancy and because that it's been
frowned upon uh by licensing Authority
so I'm worried that we are open on to
the situation when you won't be able to
honestly say to a healthy yet 18 year
olds that maybe they don't need a
commute vaccine shot could you comment
thank you sure I mean with with any such
procedure you're going to have an
informed consent you're going to talk to
this patient about the risks and the
benefits and for them particularly in
their their situation and that person I
agree is low risk and there are some
risks of side effects
um so it's not my my job to make that
decision for him is to make him an
educated person about the potential
risks and the potential benefits
obviously risk tolerance is going to be
very different Patient to Patient and
their
interpretation of each of those risks
may also be very different you know
their personal experiences with covet
and myocarditis are going to influence a
lot of their decision making so it's my
job to provide them the information on
the vaccination and to make sure they
understand that before I do anything you
know so yes I think we're particularly
Adept at doing that I think we have
conversations with patients regarding
treatment options daily about risks and
benefits and and certainly that would be
an important part of that conversation
with that individual and and it will go
different ways with different people
depending on their their experiences in
the past
okay
other questions
see no other questions okay thank you
very much and again if we could get a
copy of your written testimony
absolutely
have no one else signed up to speak on
Senate Bill 200 does anyone else wish to
testify
seeing no one else I'm going to close
the public hearing on Senate Bill 200
and open the public hearing on uh yeah
we have passed the appropriate time open
the uh
public hearing on Senate Bill 236 and
recognize the prime sponsor Senator
Shanley
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee
um for the record my name is Shannon
chandley I represent District 11 in the
state senate those are the towns of
Amherst Milford Merrimack and Wilton I
come before you today to introduce SB
236 it is a bill that establishes a
committee to study
um non-profit organizations that
contract with the Department of Health
and Human Services and this bill
um some of you may have seen a version
of this bill either the study committee
version or a policy version of the bill
one of the problems that a number of
this agencies that contract with the
state to act in lieu of the state with
regards children in particular are
running into Insurance problems they are
concerned about their ability to um be
insured sufficiently
um
some of the bills in the past have
proposed a cap on the insurance these it
was sort of like coming to the solution
before the problem had been fully
identified and considered so this is a
standard study committee that includes a
member of the Senate several members of
the house and should put out a report
after looking at the issue the Senate
improved the bill somewhat
um with an amendment uh to to
um
Define the scope or or actually that's a
broader scope it set the the way it was
in place prior
um I believe it said uh
the committee would study extended
extending limited liability the problem
with that it was is was that it was
fairly prescriptive it was identifying
the solution before looking at the
problem so this way the problem will be
identified the
um potential Solutions considered
hopefully a particular solution
recommended and the report is due out in
November
um of this year I believe
let's see I just want to make yes this
year so the report would come out this
year
um I was talking to representative
Edwards who thought that the bill needed
to have a Sunset date or a repeal of the
committee I am not sure that it is
necessary my understanding is once um
the bill comes out uh or the bill
becomes law and that this report would
be issued one time and that would be the
end of it but if the committee does
believe it's necessary to put a sunset
or repeal of this committee uh in place
that certainly is no problem obviously
the intent of the committee is to find a
solution uh now and not
um continuing hopefully a solution could
be found this summer on there I know
that there are some folks from the
agencies that are affected by this
problem who are able to speak they can
probably answer any um specific
questions better than I but I am more
than happy to take any questions you may
have
questions yes representative
all right I'm I'm feeling a little dumb
thank you for taking my question so
um
what is the problem here
like so and I was trying to think of a
non-profit children's organization so I
was thinking like Nashua children's home
so Waypoint folks from Waypoint are here
and they can explain exactly what they
are facing but the issue is that because
of um the perceived risks in delivering
this kind of care to Children uh whether
it's foster care working with any kind
of the the risks that they face that
their access to insurance coverage is
um shrinking and they are fearful that
they may lose access to insurance
coverage so this isn't insurance
coverage for the children
this is insurance coverage for the
organizations yes that are liability for
handling is difficult cases thank you I
feel much smarter now and well my
mistake I should have been clearer thank
you other questions yes representative
Merchant
and thank you Mr also
thank you for taking the question I do
understand what representative Edwards
was saying is that the way it's written
it it sort of implied that there's going
to be a dissolution of the
commission
um after November 1st but would you be
opposed to putting a sunset clause in
there basically to be clear that this is
going to end come November 2nd 2019
thank you
so you know other questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Keith Koenig
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh my name is Keith kinning
I'm the advocacy director at Waypoint we
sit here in support of SB 236
um so Waypoint serves a critical role in
the community by providing ISO level
foster care and this is foster care that
we provide in lieu of the state doing
this these are children that have been
identified as abused and neglected and
the state doesn't have the ability to
serve them we do this is the most high
level intensive foster care that you can
have this is wraparound services that
have kids that have gone through the
most horrific parts of their life almost
unbelievable a few to hear some of the
stories
um
these Services allow children to receive
community-based services in the home
there is a critical shortage of iso
foster care programs in the state and
right now we only have eight of them and
the problem that we are finding is that
our insurance company called
Philadelphia has allowed us to keep our
main policy but they have pulled away
our umbrella policy so any lawsuit that
involves us over a million dollars we no
longer can get insurance for we have
sought out other insurance and there is
other insurance out there but it is so
prohibitively expensive as to almost be
it's the same thing as not having
insurance we get a certain amount of
money every day to take care of these
kits and if the insurance is so high
that we can't pay it because our the
funding that we get from the state has
to go to the people that are taking care
of these children it's like having no
insurance at all so we sit here not as
Waypoint even though we're asking
Waypoint for Waypoint is asking for help
we're sitting here asking you to help
the kids because this is a program that
needs to continue and we just because of
everything that's happening we can't get
the insurance we need anymore in order
to
um run the program safely that any
lawsuit wouldn't impact all the other
programs that we have we have over
nearly 350 employees we serve hundreds
of Elders and CFI programs we serve the
voluntary services and right now we are
at risk that something that happens in
our ISO program could spill over that
would in fact you know impact the entire
organization so what we are merely
asking and I know I've heard this from
other committees and I know the speaker
is not crazy about commissions and
committees I understand that but last
year this bill came before children and
family law it made it that far and a
representative on the committee said I
will take care of this I will work with
the insurance Department we don't need
to set up a committee I bet I don't have
to finish what I'm going to say for you
to understand what happened was that
never happened there was no connection
with the insurance department there was
no follow-up and here we are a year
later and we're in just as much danger
of not having the insurance that we need
I know Spalding has also had their
insurance taken away from them I believe
Easter Seals I believe Lisa Britt said
she was going to send in testimony maybe
she had to see Senate online but this
isn't again just about Waypoint this is
this is a trend that's happening that um
agencies like ours are losing their
insurance and when we lose our insurance
we can't serve the children that need to
be served all we're asking is for a
committee to look into a solution to
this problem I understand and I would
have to tell you what would make me
happiest of all is if everybody was
happy with the solution and the kids
were protected that's that's the goal
we're looking to go for and so if this
involves an insurance pool that somehow
that providers of these Services could
do or any other thought thoughts that
people bring together but we can't come
to a solution to this problem until we
all sit down and talk about this and
that's what we need to do right now and
this is something that if we thought
this was a short Trend that it was going
away we wouldn't be sitting here
bothering you but because ISO is so
important to these children we would ask
you to support this bill merely to
establish a committee for us to look
into how Us and other non-profits can
find some kind of insurance company that
we can continue to protect these
children so
um that is what I'm asking and and on
behalf of the kids in these ISO foster
care programs thank you for listening
thank you yes representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question just so I'm grasping
the extent of the problem and the focus
of the committee uh when you're saying
when you're talking about the insurance
um I see the issue of liability from an
organizational point of view
and the impact it could have on other
programs if there was a catastrophic
event and a catastrophic recovery uh the
question I have is does the insurance
that you carry cover the liability of
the individual ISO foster parents as
well or is that a whole separate problem
thank you representative for the
question I can't answer that right now
but I certainly can get back to that my
understanding my understanding is this
is this is the insurance for a waypoint
this is strictly four-way point but I
will check into that with our our CEO
um and get back to you and I I want to
make everybody completely understand we
are not looking for immunity we are not
we're we are looking for the ability to
buy insurance that we can continue to
provide this program but I will get back
to you representative as soon as I can
okay representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking the question uh you know my
limited experience with these study
committees is that they identify the
problems and make suggestions of some
you know recommend some possible
solutions and it sounds like you're way
ahead of the game in in regard to this
um that you have a very specific problem
that you're trying to address and you
are the experts on it you know all about
it so
um that does that's not to say that we
don't need a study committee but
um I wonder if you
you did bring up one idea but if you've
done research into what possible
solutions there are or researched what
um
what um
nonprofits use in other states to to
deal with this problem
uh thank you for the question
um I we we do we definitely know the
problem
because we've had our insurance taken
away from us and we definitely know we
can't find Insurance in an affordable
range I think as I said before there are
many solutions out there there are um
organizations that are here that have
legitimate concerns about some of the
solutions that might be proposed and and
and they may oppose that and I think the
thing that the committee would allow us
is to get into a room and make sure I I
think the last thing all of us want is
to get to the end of the committee and
come up with a solution that people
don't agree with or that they fight
against I mean our our goal would be to
find a solution that everyone around the
table says yeah we can live with this
the insurance department the you know
the different organizations and we can
put a bill in for this next session that
would solve this problem so
um I do think we need the weight of the
committee
um to bring everybody together so that
we can work together this has been going
on now for three years
we've brought the bill on numerous
occasions like last year we thought we
were very close until the representative
said that he would take care of it
um but I
I think you're right we're very far
along except for that last piece is we
don't have a solution that everyone
agrees to and I I think that obviously
is the solution we need to get through I
don't know representative that answer
your question
follow-up follow-up yeah yes it does
answer my question and I would just say
from you know my experience that dealing
with some of the kids and families that
will be served by these um
you know wraparound intensive needs
foster homes is complicated enough
um and um it's very difficult to be
successful with the treatment
um the this shouldn't be one more
problem that you have to address yeah
and I would have to say my experience
with the committee one of the most
impactful committees I've ever watched
was Senator David Putin's committee on
dcyf
um that was Senator Putin who really
moved things forward with a lot of the
changes that happened to dcyf and funds
going into dcyf so I'm very optimistic
that with people generally caring about
the children and both sides everyone
cares about the kids we have different
perspectives on how to get there but I
would agree with you you know this would
this would be nice not to have to worry
about so much we'd like to get past this
and do the job which we do which is send
in five six seven eight people into
these homes and give these kids
wrap-around services to save their lives
and it truly is let these children have
been through they need their lives saved
they need people to come in and help put
their feedback on the ground they need
support of these foster care families
and certain this is something
administratively that if we could put
behind us it'd give us more more time to
focus on the children so thank you
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
for taking the question
what I I'm struggling with I see people
from the legislative body on this
committee which is what committee's for
however I don't see other representation
from the insurance industry and
stakeholder Community
um I think the intent here is probably
to have him come before the committee
and talk about it but would you have any
thoughts on having members who are
voting members of the kind it's kind of
a hybrid between the two where all of a
sudden you have
the voting members on the committee
comprise the legislators but also
non-voting members coming from the
insurance industry coming from other
stakeholder communities because they're
the ones that need to be at the table
it's not just legislative body but the
people at the stakeholder Community
including yourself from that part of it
as far as the people from the insurance
industry people coming from that part of
it would you I'm looking at some of the
channel lead out there as well but I
mean I think it's important we have all
the stakeholders at that table and not
just have legislative bodies there
sure sure
mm-hmm
thank you very much representative
um my understanding is that
traditionally a committee is comprised
only of legislative members and those
members of the legislature the Senate
and the house can then call on any
experts in the field and all the
stakeholders certainly they would be
charged with seeking out testimony from
the insurance department from the New
Hampshire Association for Justice from
um uh perhaps the various agencies
families that are in um anyone any
stakeholder that would be the charge of
the legislative committee what you're
describing is would really be more a com
a commission
um it is a larger undertaking and a
little bit less Nimble this bill really
is for a committee and I think a
committee can do the job if it's
properly chaired and orchestrated
thank you you're welcome representative
Weber
let's see here as as a follow-up to that
question would you believe that the one
of the most effective committees I ever
sat on uh was chaired by at the time
representative Nancy Styles then she
became went on to be a senator and it
was on the issue of truancy and she
managed to
assemble about 15 different
constituencies that uh ranged from
school school board teachers teachers
associations
homeschoolers
probation officers you name it and came
up with a very effective set of
parameters so it is a format that can be
very effective and that the experience
on that committee was that
the people who came and they all came
regularly to every meeting had such a
stake in the outcome
that they were motivated to be there
yes
I would believe and I have a follow-up
question and and isn't it true that if
you have a commission that requires the
appointment of outside people and you
start the appointment
in July when the bill is signed getting
anything actually done by November is
almost impossible yes indeed thank you
Mr chair do you mind if I just say so
representative I just want to say to you
you have my word that as part of the
committee we will make sure that
everybody that needs to be there needs
to be there because it does US
absolutely no good to get the end of
this process and have somebody that we
haven't invited come in and say we don't
we don't approve of this and so we'll be
looking anybody that we're we are happy
um and we can work with other
stakeholders to make sure if they say we
think that these people should be here
they they should all be there and the
committee has that power
um and to call anybody and we want to
work with everybody that wants to be a
part of it
any other questions I see none hey thank
also signed up to speak is Beth margison
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you very much for
allowing me to speak this morning I am
Beth margison I'm the general counsel
legislative liaison for dcyf and for all
the reasons that the previous two
speakers including the sponsor of the
bill uh said dcyf wholeheartedly
supports uh establishing this committee
to look at the reasons why insurance and
is so difficult to get for the
children's organizations that serve our
population
and that's all I have to say I'll be
happy to take any questions okay any
questions
also signed up to speak is Marissa Chase
foreign
that means my handwriting is bad
um good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak this morning my
name is Marissa Chase I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice which was
mentioned it's a euphemism for the trial
lawyers
um and I am the unfortunate naysayer of
legislation that was proposed three
years ago that would have extended the
same sovereign immunity that the state
enjoys as well as cap on damages to
these non-profits when they contract
with the state we had serious concerns
about that legislation I've been very
happy to work with Keith to get to
the study committee before you and
regardless if I am called or not I will
be at those committee meetings and offer
perhaps unsolicited input
um but you know I understand the
um you know ISO the iso Foster Care
Program is an incredible asset to the
state and it literally does save lives I
will also say that is a very small
portion of the functions that Waypoint
Easter seal Spalding Etc carry out and
when we talk about you know the the
issue of insurance you know
two things that I hope are not
contradictory
one um I remember when I was 16 years
old my car insurance under my parents
policy was very high for a good reason I
totaled my first car because I was 16
years old so their insurance premiums
were raised
um however this is also not the
insurance problem that I believe these
nonprofits are facing and I don't intend
to speak for them I believe it is an
insurance problem and not a lawsuit
problem there are very few lawyers in
this state that do the kind of work that
it takes to
sue these entities or file suit I
believe Waypoint was only and Keith
correct me if I'm wrong only I've only
ever been named in a lawsuit once in the
but it is rare for many reasons that I
can get into today or I don't have to
um but anyway this is all to say the
bill before us has been years long work
that Keith and I have engaged in and you
know we will be participating with the
hope that you know everybody understands
that this is not a lawsuit problem that
this is an insurance problem
okay thank you are you taking questions
for sure
do we have any questions
thank you thank you Mr chairman
uh I would just like to comment that
uh how impressed I have been with
Waypoint over the years that that it's
unquestionable there uh professionalism
and the commitment to the care of
children and I'm very pleased to see a
former remember be the chairman of this
legislation
she's a good friend from the past
so that I would strongly support the
passage of this legislation and be
willing to participate
in the work of it
thank you
our representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
I'm not sure I'm understanding
your comments about this is not a
lawsuit problem I get I understand that
um you're saying that these agencies
have not been sued a lot and that's why
the insurance is so high
but so what what are you saying is that
I so I represent the plaintiff's bar so
the trial lawyers
um most of the time when we are in
opposition to legislation the folks
proposing that legislation or vice versa
are insurance companies so I believe
that especially since the pandemic well
insurance companies have been enjoying
huge profits and I'm happy to provide
the committee with studies that our
national has done in surveys they have
done across the country while insurance
companies are making record profits
their insureds are not seeing the
benefit of those
I get it yeah thank you
seeing none okay thank you very much
does anyone else representative Edwards
is out in the hall or
Italy okay thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 236 does anyone else wish
to testify
saying no one else I'm going to close
the public hearing on Senate Bill 236
those are all of the bills that we had
noticed for today
so we're going to adjourn and reconvene
next Wednesday which time we have two
Senate bills left we will be hearing
both of those and then perhaps uh some
some of the more straightforward uh
bills we've already heard we may be
going into executive session on and
those will be noticed as well so thank
foreign